bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat du vent au 22 juin
prochain se tiendra au brésil à rio de
janeiro la conférence internationale des
nations unies sur le développement
durable pour ban ki moon secrétaire
général de l'onu à rio notre vision doit
être clair pour une économie verte
durable mais aussi pour une hausse des
revenus pour la création d'emplois
convenable bref pour éradiquer la
pauvreté
alors pour préparer ce sommet les
sénateurs de la commission du
développement durable et de la
commission de l'économie auditionne cet
après-midi le français pascal lamy
c'est le directeur général de l'om c'est
l'organisation mondiale du commerce sans
plus tarder donc tout de suite direction
la salle clémenceau poursuivre cette
audition
bon après midi à tous nous avons
l'honneur et le plaisir d'accueillir cet
après-midi et monsieur fils pascal lamy
qui est déjà directeur de de l'om sait
depuis 2005
ça tourne et en particulier très
investis évidemment dans les
négociations du fable au cycle de doha
etc
mais c'est pas tellement à ce titre-là
du site de doha que nous vous nous vous
attendons aujourd'hui c'est plutôt sans
doute le rio +20 et les problèmes
concernant l'environnement et en
particulier les velléités qui pourrait y
avoir un nous émeut à côté de m sais pas
je suppose je veux pas prendre la parole
à votre place avec des difficultés
institutionnelles que ça peut
représenter
il est clair que les aspects
environnementaux font partie des
négociations aussi de l'om s'est donc il
ya là une transversalité
je ne sais pas comment vous envisager
les choses monsieur le directeur
mais c'est un chantier qui est ouvert
qui vous occupera en sachant que sans
doute année 2012 avec les élections
pardon américaine j'allais dire hors les
élections américaines au mois de
novembre vont guère évolué quant aux
négociations tant que les usa ne rompt
pas une nouvelle organisation
voilà monsieur le directeur je laisse la
parole à mon collègue vraiment merci
monsieur le président donc nous ce
directeur général d'abord je vous
confirme également tout le plaisir et
l'honneur que vous faites en venant à la
rencontre du sénat et de ses deux
commissions l'une qui évidemment
présidée par daniel raoul aura sur les
thèmes économiques certainement beaucoup
de questions et puis l'autre qui
viennent de naître toute naïve tout
récent mais qui depuis déjà pour eux ce
qui concerne le climat en particulier à
créer un groupe de travail qui est donc
présidé par laurence rossignol et qui
après durban évidemment prépare rio
plusieurs blessures
comment ne pas évidemment vous
interpeller pour ce qui concerne notre
commission sur le lien entre le commerce
et l'environnement et comment ne pas
être préoccupé par son développement
fantastique évidemment les conséquences
que cela peut avoir sur le climat sur la
planète et sur l'humanité survit
donc j'ai lu récemment pour ne pas dire
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui que ainsi
concerne l'om vous n'étiez pas
défavorables je vous titille un petit
peu parce que les commentaires étaient
un petit peu comment dirais-je orient t
il sans supposer qu'on préfériez que
d'autres ça n'occupe ce qui est
certainement faux et vous avez donc pour
nous convaincre deux heures devant
mesure en tout cas je suis ravie au nom
de mes collègues ici présents de et des
services qui sont occupés de cette
rencontre de vous c'était tout de suite
la parole pour que nous puissions vous
interroger sur la fin comme c'est de
tradition
merci à vous de m'avoir convient aux
travaux à vos réflexions
je vais essayer de d'introduire aussi
brièvement que possible la discussion
est entendu que ça mon contenu nous
centrer aujourd'hui sur la préparation
de rio +20 et au fond sur comment se
présente cette échéance
vu de mon point de vue c'est à dire de
celui de directeur général de l'om c'est
ce qui évidemment amène à se poser un
certain nombre de questions selon des
relations entre au sein de la
gouvernance globale multilatérale entre
les questions environnementales et les
questions commerciales alors rions plus
20 qu'est ce que c'est à ce stade c'est
une échéance dont nous espérons qu'à
pour beaucoup d'entre nous quelle sera
un écho dignes de ceux qualité rio il ya
20 ans rio il ya vingt ans et j'ai
quelques raisons de m'en souvenir
c'était à l'époque directeur de cabinet
du président la commission européenne a
été un grand moment de coopération
internationale je dirais même que ça
fait partie de ces grands moments de
coopération internationale
années 90 donc hélas nous n'avons pas vu
la réplique depuis en gros trio 89 le
protocole de kyoto la fin le ru berne
la création de la cour pénale
internationale
donc tout moment qu'ils ont été des
moments de progrès du multilatéralisme
et doit constater hélas que à partir en
raison du milieu dès la fin des années
90 nous n'avons pas vu le nouveau
événement de ce genre de nouvelles
poussées
compte tenu du fait que entre temps les
questions environnementales que rio 92
avait mis à l'ordre du jour un moment où
c'était quand même encore assez nouveau
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
depuis ça s'est pas rangé
et que notre planète vingt ans après et
sans doute dans un état environnemental
plus préoccupant qu'ils ne l'étaient il
ya 20 ans est ce à dire que ce qui a été
lancé il ya 20 ans on n'a pas eu
d'effets non ça a eu un effet majeur qui
est de connecter la politique nationale
internationale avec ses questions de
préservation de l'environnement
même si encore une fois vingt ans après
les espoirs qu'on aurait pu avoir à
l'époque pour des tas de raisons pour
peut-être l'iran discussions n'ont pas
été réalisés donc rio +20 cette fois ci
c'est quoi bon c'est d'abord et de ce
point de vue là c'est les travaux
préparatoires entassés bien avancé c'est
d'abord l'idée qu' on a besoin pour le
21e siècle une plate forme d'une vision
d'un niveau de coopération à la mesure
des enjeux environnementaux tels qu'ils
avaient été perçus il ya vingt ans et
ceci tourne cette fois c'est autour d'un
concept complexe débattue mais qui en
gros et celui de l'économie verte sur
laquelle d'ailleurs vous plaît si j'ai
bien compris déjà penché avec un certain
nombre d'interlocuteurs ces concepts
d'économie verte qui est disons le nom
marketing
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque croissance
durable apparemment économie verte sonne
mieux que croissance durable je veux
bien l'admettre est en quelque sorte au
centre de la préparation de rio plus ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que on considère que la
durabilité de notre planète
sur le plan environnemental est très
étroitement lié à un certain nombre de
décisions de nature économique qu'il va
falloir prendre si on veut lui dire
commençait sérieusement à inverser la
courbe dont nous savons qu'elle n'est
pas bonne
la trajectoire climatologiques
environnementale de l'économie de la
planète aujourd'hui n'est pas bonne
nous savons tous que si nous ne
fléchirons pas alors on pour revendre un
certain nombre de dangers et notamment
en matière climatique
avant d'en venir au rôle précis d'une
organisation mondiale du commerce et des
changes internationales dans la
préparation de riocan vingt deux trois
considérations simple le point de départ
nous considérons l omc et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que nous disent nos
statuts tels qu'ils ont été établies
quant au mca a été créé succédant au
gatt dans les années 95 que l'ouverture
des échanges qui est le socle
idéologique qui réunit les 153 bientôt
157 ondes de rmc
est au service d'un certain nombre de
buts qui dépasse la vertu de l' échange
commercial international et son
ouverture dont dont la durabilité
environnementale le fait que l'ouverture
de l'échangeur soit au service de la
durabilité environnementale fait partie
des principes qui ont présidé à la
création du mcf de telle sorte que par
construction en quelque sorte il n'ya
pas antinomiques antagonisme entre la
préservation de l'environnement et
l'ouverture des échanges
on peut apporter à l'appui de cette
thèse un certain nombre de
considérations certaines d'ordre
théorique dans d'autres d'ordre pratique
j'ai vu me limiterai simplement à dire
que dans la mesure où l'une des vertus
de l'ouverture des échanges
c'est d'aboutir à une meilleure
utilisation des facteurs de production
que ceux ci soient de l'humain du
capital de la nature les vertus de
l'ouverture des échanges
en termes d'efficience sont une
contribution à une meilleure utilisation
des ressources naturelles je reconnais
que ceci parfois un peu contre intuitif
notamment parce que
des répandu ici ou là que l'augmentation
des changes internationale pouvait
comporter une empreinte écologique
notamment carbone négative
on y reviendra peut-être dans la
discussion toutes les études sérieuses
et tous les chiffres sérieux montrent le
contraire pour prendre un seul exemple
si l'arabie saoudite a décidé il ya
assez récemment de cesser de produire
des céréales
parce que produire des céréales en
arabie soit but c'était une un péché
contre la rareté des ressources en eau
alors
l'arabie saoudite a pris une décision
passionnel du point de vue
environnemental
la seule conséquence étant que dès lors
l'arabie saoudite doit se fournir sur le
marché international souvent acquiert
des céréales dont elle a besoin pour se
nourrir
s'il échange international de permet de
ne perdre et ne permettez pas cela alors
effectivement on aura été dans un cas de
figure qui conviera mentalement et plus
négatif
cette notion de croissance verte je ne
vous le cacherai pas ne fait pas
l'unanimité à ce stade de la préparation
de rio +20 pourquoi parce que il y a
chez les pays en développement
une vieille défiance très enracinés dans
leur opinion dans leur diplomatie chez
leurs ministres qui s'exprime d'ailleurs
commis de l'environnement commis du
commerce communiste de l'économie au
terme desquelles cette notion de
croissance verte ne serait qu' une
réinvention occidentale d'un modèle de
domination au nom duquel le nord
pourraient se livrer à ce que le sud
appellent à la protection nisme d'air et
donc il y a et je tiens à être très
précis là-dessus il y a aujourd'hui
encore autour de la table de la
préparation de rio +20
on va en discuter pas plus tard que
après demain et samedi au chief
executive board des nations du nez qui
serait une comme deux fois par an avec
l'os qatar généralisation du nil et tous
les dirigeants d' agences
internationales et un des objets de
cette réunion va être précisément
d'essayer de réduire un petit peu la
fracture qui subsistent sur ce pont donc
sachons que derrière ce vocable de
croissance verte que nous aimons il y a
encore c'est un certain nombre de pays
en développement une méfiance
une réticence qui restera là aussi
longtemps en quelque sorte qu'on n'aura
pas démontré que ce n'est pas une idée
perverse de plus pour en quelque sorte
tirer l'échelle d'une croissance à
laquelle il pense avoir droit et dont
ils savent très bien qu elle est
maintenant en concurrence avec des
systèmes économiques qui doivent
s'ajuster il interprète souvent cette
notion de croissance verte comme une
raison de plus que les pays du nord ont
trouvé pour ne pas avoir à s'ajuster à
au fond la nouvelle distribution des
cartes de l'économie et d'échangé
international qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière cette notion de croissance
verte à mes yeux deux éléments
essentiel un premier qui est la
nécessité de recourir à une boîte à
outils que j'appellerais pompeusement
faute d'autres mots pour faire vite
d'internaliser d'internet
d'internalisation de la contrainte
environnementale dans le jeu d'une
économie globale de modèle
capitalistique et puis deuxièmement
quelque chose de plus concret que cela
qui est de l'ordre de la recherche du
développement et de solutions
alternatives
autrement dit il ya deux voies derrière
cette notion de croissance verte
la première c quels sont les outils que
nous utilisons et quel dosage de ces
outils
prenons nous pour faire en sorte que les
marchés intègrent la contrainte
environnementale et là nous connaissons
la boîte à outils elle est parfaitement
identifié un la fiscalité
il ya des quotas il ya la réglementation
je suis de ceux qui pensent que la
solution n'est pas dans le choix entre
un de ces trois outils mais dans une
combinaison appropriée
chaque au cas par cas dans ces trois
outils et de soins de blain mon conseil
et c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
pour un certain nombre d'entre nous y
compris le
un des principaux responsables autour de
la table qui et hakim steiner le boss du
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement
essayons de faire en sorte que la
discussion ne porte pas sur
est ce qu'il faut verdir la croissance
lorsque ça c'est un point acquis c'est
une nécessité
mais comment le faire de manière à ce
que le débat atterrissent sur des
mesures concrètes et le deuxième volet
est effectivement celui qui porte
suffisamment d'attention des
investissements qui sont des
investissements dans la recherche dans
le développement dans la diffusion des
technologies pour tout ce qui est des
énergies propres et renouvelables
si on veut un exemple de ce qui a marché
dans le passé dans ce domaine et je le
cite souvent j'ai étudié de près et
c'est en quelque sorte mon modèle de
référence
regardons ce qui s'est passé avec le
protocole de montréal sur l'interdiction
des chlorures des chlorofluorocarbones
qui a endommagé la couche d'ozone
voilà un bon exemple d'un mélange
adéquat de réglementation de recherche
et comme par hasard le protocole de
montréal qui a été un très très grand
succès comme chacun sait résulte
justement de ce mélange d'une vision
internationale multilatérale comportant
d'ailleurs éventuellement des mesures
commerciales qui en n'ayant jamais eu à
être utilisé mais en même temps
simultané avec la découverte et la mise
sur le marché de produits de
substitution au cfc qui ont permis en
quelque sorte trop protocole de montréal
de fonctionner donc ça c'est en quelque
sorte à mes yeux le premier le premier
volet est au fond l'essentiel de la base
conceptuelle de ce que devrait être une
une économie nerfs quel est le rôle de
l'échangé international et de l'om c'est
en tant qu organisation multilatérale
c'est un rôle d'appui c'est un rôle de
contribution a commencé d'ailleurs à
commencer d'ailleurs par fournir aux
pays en développement dont je disais à
l'instant il était encore extrêmement
soupçonneux de cette notion d'économie
verte
à commencer par leur fournir petite
espèce de d'assurance anti
protectionnisme que l'om s'est fourni
les textes du mc jurisprudence de l'om
cm et notamment du mécanisme de
règlement des différends depuis que
depuis qu'il existe depuis 90 crec 2.95
établissent un équilibre extrêmement
particules et précis sophistiqué entre
les contraintes de la préservation de
l'environnement d'un côté et le
contraintes de l'ouverture des échanges
de l'autre on résumer ce que disent les
textes et l'interprétation des textes de
rethel qui a été fait par le mécanisme
de règlement des différends c'est que
les pays ont le droit à des fins de
protection de leur environnement comme
d'ailleurs de la complice de leur
population de leurs plans de leurs
animaux de mettre des restrictions aux
échanges
au nom de la préservation de
l'environnement la côte est n'est que de
l'autre côté il faut s'assurer au cas
par cas que ces mesures de restrictions
aux échanges sont légitimes
du point de vue de leurs objectifs la
préservation de l'environnement de là
santé etc et qu'elles ne sont pas des
mesures de protectionnisme déguisé
ça c'est la fonction d'utilité si je
puis dire
et de fait d'ailleurs c'est au cas par
cas à chaque fois qu'il ya un
contentieux à l'om sait et on a eu
un certain nombre depuis une quinzaine
d'années sur ces questions y compris des
très récent petit à petit les conditions
de cet équilibre ont été précisés dans
certains cas ce sont les préoccupations
environnementales qui ont prévalu je
prends le cas le cas en france contre
canada sur l'amiante
voilà un cas dans d'autres cas ce sont
des préoccupations de proportionnalité
commerciales qui ont prévalu les jurés
ont estimé que dans un certain nombre de
cas les mesures commerciales qui était
mise en oeuvre étaient disproportionnés
par rapport à l'objectif de protection
de l'environnement et surtout qu'elle
comportait sinon un soupçon en tout cas
un risque de n'être autre chose que des
mesures déguisée de pour favoriser les
producteurs domestiques
donc de ce point de vue là l'om sait de
par ses principes de par ses textes de
par son activité de par son expérience
peut contribuer à en quelque sorte
stabiliser cette notion selon laquelle
croissant air ne signifie pas risque de
protectionnisme vert autre contribution
que nous pouvons apporter c'est des
choses qui sont plus proches de notre
activité quotidienne et notamment qui
sont en cours dans la négociation du
programme de développement de va qui
comme vous l'avez dit à juste titre tout
à l'heure n'est pas dans sa meilleure
forme par les temps qui courent en
raison pourrait revenir d accord assez
fondamentale entre
les etats-unis et les pays émergents
mais il y a
dans l'ordre du jour des négociations
omc
il y a plusieurs sujets qui pourraient
devraient être pris en compte dans cette
notion de croissance verte dans quelques
mois par you je pense en particulier à
la partie de la négociation qui lisent à
favoriser l'ouverture des échanges en
matière de biens et de services
environnementaux et énorme marché
si dans un certain nombre de cas demeure
excessivement protéger qu'il s'agisse
des cellules photovoltaïques qu'il
s'agisse des services de conseil sur le
climat qu'ils s'agissent des éoliennes
qui sévissait cuisinière solaire tous
ses biens et tous ces services font
encore l'objet d'obstacles échanges qui
ont renchéri le coût et qui donc retard
dans quelque sorte leur pénétration sur
des marchés des technologies propres
autre exemple dont on parle y ait de
manière connexe ya un instant le
président la pêche
il y a aujourd'hui un mandat de
négociation à l'om celle qui consiste à
établir une un système multilatéral de
discipline sur les subventions à la
pêche étant entendu que nous savons tous
qu'il y as surpêche et nous avons tous
qu'une partie de cette surpêche tient à
des capacités de pêche excessives qui
ont été entretenues par un système de
subventions qui de ce point de vue là
est totalement en contradiction avec le
principe général de préservation des
ressources halieutiques
donc voilà voilà donc trois exemples
dans lesquels nous pouvons avoir
en tant que régulateur commerce
bilatéral
un apport qui va dans le sens de la
construction d'une queue comme hiver
encore une fois si possible la v2 ce
soupçon protectionnistes
autre point pour rio +20 sur lequel j'ai
compris que vous aviez aussi déjà un
certain nombre de débats de réflexions
c'est tout ce qui concerne l'
architecture de la gouvernance
internationale en matière
d'environnement et notamment ceux qui
tournent autour de cette idée d'une
organisation mondiale de l'environnement
comme vous le savez là aussi les
positions sont encore assez diverses
entre les partisans d'une architecture
qui rationalisent en quelque sorte la
gouvernance de l'environnement au plan
multilatéral
non pas que cette gouvernance n'existe
pas et l'existant il y à 200 d'accords
multilatéraux qui sont en fonction en
matière d'environnement il y a un
programme des nations-unies pour
l'environnement il y a la commission du
développement soutenable
on a changé les dix ans on peut être à
juste titre un peu préoccupé ils ont dû
un certain désordre et d'où l'idée
qu'une fois de mettre davantage d'ordre
avec une énergie et une structure qui
soit fusionne ses diverses organisations
ces diverses conventions leur
secrétariat leur administration
d'un autre côté une autre thèse étant
afk après tout la gouvernance
internationale n'est pas une affaire
d'esthétique
c'est une affaire au d'efficacité et que
avant de chambouler le système de
recréer des organisations tour nous
savons tous qu elles ont une petite
tendance au surpoids bureaucratique
en tout cas au plan interne
nal il faut être capable de démontrer
que le résultat sera plus efficace du
point de vue de l'utilisation des moyens
et des résultats que ceux ci apportera à
la préservation de l'environnement
ce sont en gros les termes du débat il y
a et c'est bien compréhensible c'est un
certain nombre de participants à ce
débat et et notamment la république
française dont nous savons qu'ils ont le
goût de l'ordre des colonnes bien
établis et des frontispice bien
clarifiée il y a une tendance à dire il
faut de l'ordre et donc il faut créer
une organisation una de l'environnement
il y a encore une fois dans notre sens
des cultures un peu différente
je ne prends pas parti à ce stade
simplement pour dire que du point de vue
de la régulation du commerce
international
du point de vue de l'om sait et ce sera
mon point final tout ce qui va dans le
renforcement de la gouvernance
multilatérale de l'environnement est une
bonne chose
l'om c'est s'occupe de la régulation de
les changes multilatérale l'organisation
mondiale de la santé fait la même chose
en matière de santé l'organisation
internationale des télécommunications
fait la même chose en matière de
télécommunications donc nous avons un
système spécialisé
il se trouve que parce que le commerce
connect beaucoup de ces domaines c'est
un peu le centre de gravité de la
relation entre ces différents systèmes
pourquoi parce que on échange et quand
on échange on passe par le commerce
international
mais nous ne sommes pas et l'om senah ni
ambition ni location de par ses textes
et sa constitution d'être des
régulateurs sectoriels en plus en
matière de banque et d'assurance que de
santé que de sécurité des aliments que
de télécommunications que de santé des
animaux
toutes ces domaines de la régulation
internationale sont confiés à des
organisations spécialisées et du point
de vue de l'environnement
nous ne voyons que des avantages parce
que il y est une gouvernance
multilatérale qui fixe les standards
nécessaires
on avait les reins assez bon exemple
avec ce que la communauté internationale
a essayé de faire depuis quelques années
de copenhague en connais de cancun ans
norman pour essayer de mettre sur pied
un système de discipline et latérale sur
la réduction des émissions de carbone
je sais pas vous expliquer tout ça vous
connaissez touchera aussi bien que moi
le fait est que aujourd'hui l'absence
d'un système de discipline
internationale dans lesquels les
obligations et les droits des uns et des
autres en matière d'émissions de carbone
n'est pas stabilisé et je le crains
n'est pas tout à fait prêt de l'être
fait peser sur les changes
internationales un risque le risque
étant celui de mesures unilatérales non
pas d'ailleurs que des mesures y latéral
soit systématiquement condamnable ou
condamnés et là dessus que je dois
respecter une grande prudence parce que
le des vielles omc ne peut pas
s'exprimer sur ce qui peut être devenir
assez vite des cas contentieux ne serait
ce qu'en raison du rôle que j'ai dans le
dans la gestion du mécanisme de
règlement des différends mais il est
clair que du point de vue de la
stabilité de la prévisibilité de la
transparence le champ de les chances de
l'international
plus il y a deux normes internationales
et mieux nous nous portons parce que à
partir du moment où il ya une norme
internationale toutes mesures
commerciales de restrictions aux
échanges qui est fondée sur cette norme
internationale est a priori en
conformité avec le droit de l'om s'est
donc ça c'est un principe qui est admis
à l'om c'est c'est lorsque il n'y a pas
de standard international ou lorsque il
n'y a pas de standard international
public
vous savez sans doute que dans matière
environnementale comme ailleurs on
assiste à une certaine prolifération des
standards privé qui pour les opérateurs
économiques n'ont pas valeur de loi met
en valeur de fait si je suis producteur
de fleurs au mandat et que l'union
européenne à une norme standard sur le
maximum de résidus de pesticides je sais
à quoi m'en tenir
je dois faire en sorte que mon système
de production de fleurs respecte la
norme européenne
si carrefour houle mart ou tesco qui se
font concurrence en se tirant des bourgs
plus verte les unes que les autres
décident que ils vont aller au delà de
la norme internationale qui est la norme
européenne parce que carrefour vend plus
vert que tesco qui vont plus vert que
wall mart à ce moment là moi producteurs
d'euros
rwandaise je suis dans la mouise je ne
sais plus à quel saint me vouer
et en plus il va falloir que je fais des
investissements à chaque fois dont je ne
sais pas quel est le dur et qu'elle
était en quel est le terme et qu'elle
est quelle est la consistance donc pour
terminer quelle que soit la réponse qui
sera donnée à cette question de la bonne
architecture de la remise en ordre de la
gouvernance internationale en matière
environnementale du point de vue de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce tout
ce qui va
quelles que soient les modalités
architectural que l'on que l'on retient
tout ce qui va dont le fait qu' il y
aura davantage de normes qu'elles sont
multilatéral reconnu et appliquée par
tout le monde nous simplifiera la vie et
nous évitera d'avoir au cas par cas a
statué sur telle ou telle mesure
unilatérale
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
introduction je pense que j'ai fait don
de mon point de vue un tour sinon précis
du moins relativement complet des
différentes questions qui se posent à
nos yeux dans cette préparation à
laquelle nous sommes évidemment très
étroitement associés et je pense que le
temps est maintenant venu de répondre à
vos questions en vous remerciant de
votre attention
merci le directeur général y at il des
questions des prises de ris j'ai pris
aux dettes
monsieur ronan dantec hooker laurence
evelyne jean monsieur foucher vraiment
ah non monsieur le président
cette demande de grolles jeu directeur
général alors dans l'ordre chronologique
des demandes d'interview merci monsieur
le président j'ai été très intéressé par
votre intervention monsieur et je crois
que notamment dès le début j'ai eu une
partie de la réponse de ce que je
souhaitais vous poser comme question à
la fin c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
donc je me permets de la reposer vous
avez commencé en disant que l'ouverture
des échanges était le socle idéologique
de l'om sait mais que ça reste est dans
la suite logique des accords du gatt
d'un au service d'un certain nombre de
buts peut autre que l'om c est là dedans
vous incluez la durabilité
environnementale
donc c'est vrai que pendant
plusieurs interventions j'ai pu être
amené moi à poser la question de savoir
si par rapport à des organismes le
rebond l'onu l'unesco le nes la fao
peut-être et d'autre est ce que les
objectifs de l'om c'est son supérieur
oblige les autres à suivre les
directives du lot et musset ou au
contraire est-ce qu'on peut être amené à
penser que celle omc qui doit parfois
prendre en compte
alors de quelle manière je sais qu'on a
eu parfois l'occasion de parler des
facteurs légitimes notamment quand on
aborde les problèmes de des
particularités européenne la durabilité
mais également dans le domaine social
dans le domaine de la santé la sécurité
alimentaire sanitaire etc
est ce qu'il ya des possibilités
d'évoluer dans ce domaine là de manière
à ce que justement on tienne compte de
tous ces problèmes là à l'om c est là la
fin de votre intervention lorsque vous
dites que quel que soit l'architecturé
internationale
enfin qu'on réfléchisse vous n'êtes pas
contre le fait d'avoir davantage de
normes multilatéral applicable par tous
soit dans une structure différente soit
manière ou d'une autre intégré le lycée
si c'est intégrer l omc moi ça me paraît
tout à fait satisfaisant si c'est une
autre structure le problème se pose est
que cette structure-là aura-t-elle
l'obligation de suivre les principes de
l'om c'est la libre concurrence et c'est
au contraire risquera une confrontation
où la suprématie de l'une sur l'autre
rossignol d'entre nous et ancien
directeur merci pour cette cet exposé
mais mes questions mais on peut
prolonger celle de ma collègue il ya un
instant est d'abord frais on tire quand
même notre notre perplexité notre
inquiétude quand même à quelques
semaines de la tenue du sommet de rio
+20 et une attitude globale d'ailleurs à
l'égard des négociations internationales
du multilatéralisme et de la capacité
depuis plusieurs années à produire
réellement des engagements
internationaux qui puisse permettre de
penser qu'ils ont d'un point d'appui
réel pour les pays qui s'inscrivent dans
cette dynamique
ma question de pour trace sur l'effectif
dans l'articulation entre rio +20 et la
croissance verte et votre propre
structure est vous avez à juste titre
relevés en début d'intervention que le
thème de la croissance verte faisait pas
l'unanimité dans les raisons que vous
avez effectivement indiqué ensemble de
pays craignent que ce soit un prétexte
pour les confisquer leur les voix de
leurs propres au développement
économique
et puis aussi d'autres pays font valoir
que dans les thèmes de rio cette année
disparaissent aussi tout ce qu'ils
étaient les piliers du développement
durable en particulier dimension sociale
et que c'est une autre des inquiétudes
qui pèsent sur ce sommet est de ce point
de vue je dans les les questions qu'on
se pose comment on peut articuler et
rendre compatible à la fois les
questions de croissance verte qui sont
éminemment économique et dont ils
tiennent production et aux échanges les
règles que vous développez et auquel
vous veillez et la nécessaire
intervention des politiques publiques
pour faire transiter notre économie
d'une économie carbone et productiviste
vers une économie plus
vers un nouveau modèle de développement
et en particulier comment on articule
les questions de l'éco conditionnalité
des aides les questions de dumping
social et environnemental avec les
règles du commerce international ça
c'est ma première interrogation
la deuxième serait peut-être un peu plus
plus plus précise qu est ce que vous
pensez que mc peut apporter à rio +20
vous même dans le propre cycle dans
lequel vous êtes dans le cycle de doha
et du développement et quelles
perspectives vous avez sur l'avenir des
négociations pour vous même merci
d'alterner monsieur jean bizet merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général ma question est très
voisines des questions qui viennent
d'être posés par les deux précédents
intervenants on n'a pas évoqué encore
actuellement au cours de vos propos de
le principe de réciprocité
mais c'était sous-entendu bien
évidemment c'était au coeur du g20 ya
encore quelques mois
je voudrais poser la question suivante
aujourd'hui l'om n'existe pas et
n'existera peut être demain si on
regarde avec précision l'architecturé
administrative de l'om c'est au travers
de la correspond à ses autres on peut
considérer qu'en pointillé existe
précisément certain nombre de règles
qu'il suffit aujourd'hui de formaliser
donc ma question sur sur l'environnement
sur le social et la ma question est la
suivante est ce que l'évolution de l'om
c'est va se faire je dirais par
l'addition de jugement qui feront
jurisprudence donc à la mode anglo saxon
ou bien l'om c'est va édicter elle même
deux nouvelles règles précisément
certain nombre d'accords de façon à
intégrer dans les échanges commerciaux
internationaux pour respecter ce
principe de réciprocité moi je dis
souvent chaque époque a ses vérités si
hier au travers je dirais du concept
tout sauf les armes
il était logique de donner un certain
nombre de pays émergents le temps de se
mettre entre guillemets aux normes
il est aujourd'hui plus que nécessaire
de permettre à ces pays ou d'exiger plus
exactement de ces pays de respecter un
certain nombre de règles parce que
aujourd'hui le je deviendrai par trop je
dirais inéquitable et au regard de
l'environnement ou du social
particulièrement dommageable pour ces
deux c2 de paramètres donc en clair ma
question est la suivante est ce que on
s'achemine au fil du temps vers une
architecture administrative de la mc kay
l'addition de jugement qui feront
jurisprudence
ou bien vous allez carrément aller plus
vite et plus loin et dictée vous même
tout pendant que l'on aimé n'existe pas
de nouvelles normes qui seront j'dirais
au coeur du principe de réciprocité
merci monsieur ronan dantec
oui monsieur le directeur vous avez pris
deux exemples en introduction la sur les
cfc qui est un bon exemple mais qui a la
particularité d'être un exemple d'une
extrême simplicité un problème un trou
un produit des possibilités de
remplacement de ce qui ne correspond pas
aujourd'hui à l'extrême complexité des
questions environnementales règle le
client c'est autant de tiroirs de
problèmes et de conséquences économiques
que que quelques questions sur la table
et l'autre exemple que j'ai pris je
partage tout à fait votre analyse pour
dire on a eu un peu une décennie les
années 90 un peu miraculeuse en termes
d'avancées du multilatéralisme et qui
correspondait aussi un moment historique
après la chute de l'urss où les
affrontements de blogs n'étaient plus
les mêmes que ce qu'ils avaient étés
précédents
donc on n'est pas on n'est pas dans ce
monde là aujourd'hui et donc il faut
importer de nouvelles
régulation la difficulté quand on a donc
c'est face à cette extrême complexité
c'est de re simple y fier quand ça
devient trop complexe et qu'il ya trop
de sujets sur la table il faut essayer
de simplifier un peu les choses donc
plusieurs questions par rapport à ça
est-ce que d'une certaine manière
l'om où le pnue enfin renforcer
peu importe finalement en sortant une
question un certain nombre de questions
environnementales en termes de
régulation de l'om sait ne vous
simplifierait pas la tâche
il y aurait des règles décidées ailleurs
ce qui fait que vous vous travaillerez
un peu plus facilement à ce niveau là et
est ce que nous venons y auriez donc pas
un véritable intérêt
l'autre question derrière qui à mon avis
la question clé qui dans cette absence
de confiance moi je suis les
négociations internationales sur le
climat depuis plusieurs années donc je
mesure le niveau de défiance entre les
uns et les autres tels qui a éclaté au
grand jour à copenhague notamment c'est
que on voit bien qu'on est en lisière
d'un blocage fort c'est à dire
aujourd'hui votre machine est totalement
grippé mais on peut pas dire qu'elle ait
car c'est elle écrit p on est en lisière
du fait qu'elle soit cassée c'est à dire
que notamment l'europe aujourd'hui les
discours qu'y monde politiquement sont
des discours de dire ça ne marche pas
comme ça on va commencer à gré à casser
le jeu en tout cas remettre d un certain
nombre de barrières par l'environnement
ou par le par le social et que donc
votre machine elle peut passer de grippe
et a cassé et est ce que les pays les
grands émergents
conscient de ce risque là sont à votre
avis alors je suis embêté parce que vous
avez aussi un devoir de réserve donc
vous pouvez pas oublier comment répondre
exactement aux questions mais est ce que
vous pensez quand même un que l'écran
émergents sont conscients de ce risque
là dont ils seront des grands perdants
et qu'à partir de là ils sont prêts à
bouger en termes de régulations
environnementales notamment question
connexes et est-ce que vous pensez que
l'europe aujourd'hui a les capacités y
compris au vu de ses intérêts
économiques d'aller au delà de
déclarations un peu de maths à mort en
disant vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir mais en fait vu les intérêts
croisés l'europe ne le fera jamais et et
3 est ce que ça ne veut pas dire que
derrière on va changer de logiciel et
paradis ce qui ne remet pas en cause le
fait de la nécessité
l'om c'est qu'ils que ce qui manque
aujourd'hui c'est une garantie planifié
de rattrapage au moins pour les grands
émergents par rapport aux économies des
anciens pays développés écartement oui
sur la table une garantie un peu
planifié faut encore trouver les formes
de la planification mais un peu
planifiée du fait que à terme dans le
courant du siècle les uns et les autres
ont à peu près au même niveau de
développement et bassar et ça
permettrait trouver les régulations et
compris sur les questions
environnementales qui risque
effectivement mécaniquement de casser la
machine mais on parle de planification
de parole et évelyne dit il merci
président monsieur lamy merci pour votre
les éclairages que vous nous avez
apporté et je voudrais d'abord faire une
remarque vous avez indiqué que vous
aviez comme objectif principal donc
l'ouverture des échanges et qu'il n'y
avait pas antagonisme avec le
développement durable
je fais une découverte
c'est à dire que ça m'a surpris alors
est ce que vous pourriez préciser ce que
cela signifie est ce que ça veut dire
que c'est un a priori mais qu'en réalité
ce n'est ce n'est pas votre objet est ce
que
dans ce cas ça pourrait vouloir dire que
l'om sait se saisirait de sujets je
prends un exemple concret nous avons
déçu des difficultés en ce moment à à
régler certaines questions qui se passe
dans les eaux internationales
est ce que par exemple ça ne pourrait
pas concerné directement l'om sait
puisque c'est directement les échanges
et or des compétences des pays ou des
zones
est ce que ça ne pourrait pas être là un
exemple type de ce que l'om c'est pour
fr auquel cas l'om sait se saisissant de
ce type de sujet on aurait peut-être
moins tendance à vouloir créer une web
eux que pour l'instant beaucoup
appellent de leurs voeux pourquoi parce
que on a l'impression que il faudra bien
que il y à un moment donné un organisme
qui disent eh bien c'est ma
préoccupation principale
alors si ce n'est pas aux lots et me kyi
qui se lassent pourrait-il être vous
avez évoqué la possibilité
d'internaliser des coups mais qui peut
en prendre l'initiative
est ce que finalement l'om c'est ne
pourrait pas être bien placé pour
prendre ce genre de débat en compte dans
le travail qui est fait sachant que si
on laisse aller trop loin ces sujets
sans s'en occuper ils finiront par nous
revenir en boomerang et qu'à un moment
donné ça sera tellement fort que je
pense aux plages souillées et aux dégâts
que peuvent faire les pétroliers on a vu
que aujourd'hui on a on a des soucis
avec les
et jugements qui ont été rendus est-ce
que là ça ne serait pas la meilleure des
façons de dire eh bien on est
véritablement concernés dans le commerce
international par ces questions parce
que lorsque vous dites il est par
construction donc c'est la meilleure
utilisation des ressources humaines du
capital et de la nature
mon esprit me dit le mot je remplace le
mot utilisation par le mot exploitation
et ça me va je pense que ça décrit
beaucoup mieux la réalité
merci monsieur foucher
je dirais tout simplement de d'optymo
vous avez évoqué les désordres vous avez
évoqué la remise en ordre des besoins de
remise en ordre au niveau international
la question est toute simple c'est quel
rôle particulier peut jouer la france où
pourra jouer la france pour aider à
cette remise en ordre
merci monsieur oui alors remis sûr quand
on passe le dernier on a à peu près j'ai
toutes les questions alors moi je vais
imposer 2 finalement alors la première
elle découle de ce qu'a dit didier parce
que moi aussi j'étais frappé c'est même
plus précis que ce qui a été évoqué même
didier c'est que vous avez donc préciser
que ce sont les statuts qui dépassait le
problème économique et qui prévoit la
durabilité environnementale
alors la question quand on dirige un
organisme qui a dans ses statuts de ce
prêt de préserver la durabilité
environnementale
est-ce que cet organisme a fait une
évaluation du la conséquence du deux
bancs extraordinaire du commerce
international parce que ne pas dire on
va attendre cet organisme secret en
attendant et évidemment on sait bien que
ces mêmes pays qui ont peut-être
quelques quelques peur de voir à travers
cette croissance verte qui leur serait
imposée nous forme de 2 à nouveau de
protectionnisme mise en seront pour
certains les premières victimes
donc voila moi je voudrais savoir si
vous avez vous engagez une analyse des
répercussions de ce commerce
international sur plan de du climat
autre question elle est bon et
dimensions inférieures mais commune en
commission on s'occupe de d'aménagement
de territoire
le rapporteur est partie sur des encore
numérique alors il ya une question qui a
émergé pendant ces discussions
comment finance-t-on le désagrément
numérique d'un pays alors on a des
chiffres et on est tous arrivé à la
conclusion que ce n'est pas en taxant
uniquement les opérateurs ceux qui ont
mis les tuyaux que nous pouvons y
arriver est alors s'est posé la question
je pense que la commission financière du
sénat s'est penché dessus en disant oui
mais on a oublié quelque chose on a
oublié ce qui met un contenu dans les
tuyaux et dont les bénéfices vont passer
de quatre milliards à 15 milliards en
l'espace de cinq ans alors je vais
savoir si avec le recul internationale
vous n'auriez pas une petit quitter pour
la france et qu'on aille plus vite pour
désenclaver les territoires français en
matière numérique et de rebondir sur les
derniers textes que nous avons eu à
débattre ac
en tous les cas sur l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur directeur général je
voudrais rebondir c'est une des
questions qui ont été posées parce que
si l'om s'est laissé de côté le côté
environnemental sous prétexte qu en le
laissant de côté on peut avancer plus
vite dans le cycle de doha
j'ai en souvenir que le problème de
l'agriculture avait été mis sous le
tapis et que ça n'ait pas provoqué
d'avancées considérables dans les
négociations avec à côté sans doute
assez naïf de la part de la france et de
l'europe dans cette discussion est donc
en vous en mettant de côté le côté
environnemental est ce que vous pensez
que ça va des grippés et si tu veut
populaire et jusque savent à dégripper
ce site de négociations voilà pour cette
première série de questions monsieur
directeur général
à vaisselle la parole bien j'allais
prendre bien entendu les unes après les
autres sur le sur la première question
qui est dans quelle est la hiérarchie
des priorités et des disciplines les
unes par rapport aux autres dont le
système international
la réponse est claire il n'y a pas de
hiérarchie
tous ces accords internationaux que ce
soit ceux de l'om c'est pour ce qui
concerne la régulation du commerce
international que ce soit les accords
multilatéraux sur l'environnement que ce
soit des traités quel que soit le sujet
engage autant les uns que les autres
les états nations souverains qui les ont
souscrit c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit la
convention de vienne sur les traités
tous ces engagements sont de niveau
juridique équivalent et c'est d'ailleurs
un des principes de la théorie
westphalienne qui est celle qui ouver ns
organisation du système international
aujourd'hui que c'est adesina nations
souverains de contracter ou de
décontracter des obligations
internationales étant entendu que ils
sont eux mêmes juges de la cohérence
entre les engagements qu'ils prennent
dans ces différents domaines
c'est le cadre sujet dont nous débattons
s'ouvrant par exemple entre les normes
sociales fondamentales et les règles du
commerce international
les états membres de l'organisation
internationale du travail ont souscrit
un certain nombre d'engagements sur une
norme sociale fondamentale
l'interdiction du travail des enfants du
monde droits syndicaux
parité hommes femmes etc et ils sont
tenus par ses obligations en tant que
membres de l'oit et ayant pris ces
engagements
ce sont en gros les mêmes membres qui
sont membres de lo n'diaye et en tant
que besoin mc ils ont pris un certain
nombre d'engagements qui comporte des
disciplines et des limitations à leur
souveraineté en matière de conduite de
leur politique commerciale extérieure
est-ce qu'il y en a un qui est plus fort
que l'autre non c'est équivalent nous
savons tous bien qu'en réalité partie de
cette équivalence et virtuels elle est
virtuelle dans la mesure où dans le
monde contemporain
un des privilèges de la souveraineté
c'est l'incohérence
il reste juge en tant que souverain de
la cohérence de leur engagement dans un
certain nombre de cas le système
international à jeter des ponts de
cohérence entre l'om c'est
l'organisation la propriété
intellectuelle il ya un pont juridique
qui s'appelle d'accord sur des aspects
commerciaux de la propriété
intellectuelle en matière et j'y
reviendrai dès l'instant où matière
d'environnement il y a d'ores et déjà un
pont dans l'accord sur les dernières
techniques au commerce
dans l'accord sur les normes sanitaires
et phytosanitaires entre la gouvernance
environnementale et la gouvernance ce
commercial ce qui fait la particularité
de l'organisation n'a lu commerce et qui
je le reconnai volontier donne parfois
l'impression qu'elle exerce une sorte de
surplomb c'est la spécificité de son
mécanisme de règlement des différends
dans la gouvernance internationale
encore une fois un archipel
d'institutions spécialisées
mais le mécanisme de règlement de
l'organisation internationale du travail
est bien pâle à côté de celui de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce mais
le mécanisme de règlement des différends
qui figurerait et dieu sait qu'il y en a
des pages et des pages et des pages dans
protocole de kyoto n'a jamais vraiment
été mis en oeuvre ne serait d'ailleurs
que parce que on attrape mal à la tête
la troisième page et qui après il y aura
encore 25 donc ça là il ya une
spécificité de l'organisation du
commerce qui tient au fait qu'elle a
c'est le seul mécanisme de règlement des
différends obligatoire dans le droit
international
comme vous le savez il n'y en a pas
d'autre si vous allez si vous traînez un
autre état devant la cour de l'aed la
cour de la haye et va dire qui a tort et
qui a raison
mais chacune des deux parties et
notamment la partie perdante va garder
sa souveraineté et la capacité de dire
j'ai perdu mais je ne paye pas parce
qu'elle est souveraine
halloween c'est du fait que quand on
perd on peut être soumis à des sanctions
commerciales
le mécanisme de règlement des déviants
et effectivement obligatoires ça c'est
une des grandes différences et c'est la
grande différence et c'est ce qui
conduit naturellement d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'entre vous et je le
conçois très bien à se dire de son temps
mais attendez la claque ça se passe la
claque des différents de ce type sont
tranchées effectivement dans des
conditions telles que on était obligés
d'en appliquer les conséquences la
vérité c'est que c'est pas tellement que
le mécanisme de
des règlements différents nous sommes c
est trop fort c'est que celui des autres
est trop faible
et là il ya un sujet majeur y compris on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
dans la discussion
y compris en matière d'accords
multilatéraux sur l'environnement
de mon point de vue l'existence d'un
mécanisme de règlement des différends
fait partie de la boîte à outils d'une
gouvernance globale efficace dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui il faut des normes
en dur
une des raisons pour lesquelles il faut
des normes en dur c'est que les normands
durs peuvent être interprétées par un
juge alors que d'énormes en nous par
définition sont plus floues et comporte
d'une marge d'interprétation plus grande
est d'ailleurs en général c'est les gens
ne pas passer des normands nous à des
normands dur c'est parce que ils n'ont
pas envie d'être coincé dans une
interprétation précise donc il ne s'agit
pas de savoir si l'environnement est
intégrée ou pas le même s'il est intégré
à l'om c'est comme j'ai dit deux par ses
statuts parce que l'ouverture des
échanges est une fin au service de
l'amélioration de l'emploi de la
croissance et du développement durable
tout ça c'est écrit dans le frontispice
de la constitution du mc et il est par
ailleurs aux termes de la convention de
vienne
donc ça n'est pas le commerce contre ou
à côté de l'environnement le commerce y
à l'environnement et à la santé il ya
les télécommunications il ya l'aviation
civile et tout ça doit fonctionner sur
un pied d'égalité
l'inquiétude global laurence sur la
santé uniterra date du multilatéralisme
je les dis je crois en introduction je
la partage nous sommes dans une période
où la gouvernance internationale piétine
dans un monde qui ne cesse de se
globaliser de s'interconnecter de
s'intégrer de par l'économie la culture
les moyens de communication la
technologie et ses jeux pour offert un
long exposé sur la mondialisation et
l'a77 hiatus entre des problèmes qui
sont de plus en plus globaux et
l'incapacité de la gouvernance
internationale elle est très correct à
les traiter correctement et
effectivement préoccupantes
nous sommes dit tout à l'heure depuis la
fin des années 90 dans une période de
creux ceci pour deux raisons
pendant en gros une quinzaine d'années à
cause de ce que jean michel severino en
vain un excellent bouquin long je
recommande la lecture à toutes et à tous
ici qu'il a publiée à quelques mois a
appelé le grand basculement
c'est à dire cette formidable
transformation géopolitique qui fait que
l'année 2012 est l'année charnière avant
le poids économique des pays en
développement était supérieur le poids
économique des pays développés était
supérieur à celui des pays en
développement après 2012
le poids économique des pays en
développement est supérieur à celui des
pays développés
c'est l'année c'est l'année où ça
bascule
ceci entraîne des modifications
absolument considérable et notamment de
nature géopolitique et le temps qu'il
faut à ces nouveaux équilibres pour
trouver leur place que ce soit l'om
c'est que ce soit la fao que ce soit ou
fmx ce soit la banque mondiale que ce
soit
l'organisation internationale de
l'ascendant des nations est un temps
politique qui est beaucoup plus lent que
le temps de ces transformations
économiques
ça c'est la première raison qui fait que
le système international qui en gros
avaient été organisées depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale avec un or
d'un côté un sud de l'autre un monde
dans lequel les riches et des puissants
et les pauvres étaient faibles
ce monde a changé et on a maintenant des
pays pauvres mais puissant et d'ailleurs
la controverse de savoir si on peut être
pauvre et pulse en est précisément ce
qui bloque le cycle de doigts je le lui
dis publiquement sous d'autres formes je
le redis ici ce qui bloque le cycle de
doha
c'est un désaccord entre en gros les
américains à côté et les chinois de
l'autre qui porte sur la question de
savoir si la chine et d'une manière
générale les pays émergents sont des
pays riches avec beaucoup de pauvres ou
des pays pauvres avec beaucoup de riches
et selon la réponse que vous donnez à
cette question alors les conséquences
que vous en tirez le point de vue des
droits et des obligations dans le
système international est
fondamentalement différent et là je
touche à la question est de monsieur
bizet sur la réciprocité dans le système
commercial international comme
d'ailleurs dans le système de
gouvernance environnementale les
principes qui ont gouverné les 50 ou les
façons dernières années était un mélange
de réciprocité entre les riches et de
flexibilité pour les plus pauvres
à l'om stay s'appelle traitement spécial
et différencié dans notre jargon dans
dans le jargon environnementale ça
s'appelle responsabilités communes mais
différenciées sa porte pas de nom mais
ça dit la même chose il ya une part de
réciprocité il ya une part de
flexibilité et la sécurité et au nom du
fait que des pays en développement qui
ont encore besoin de se développer ne
faut pas souscrire pour des tas de
raisons à la fois à pratiquer de
capacité est aussi juridique et
politique les mêmes obligations que des
pays riches ce monde simple c'est
terminé on a maintenant des pays riches
des pays pauvres et entre les deux des
pays émergents dont encore une fois la
question de savoir s'ils sont riches
mais paumé paumé riches tous les riches
ou semi pauvres n'est pas réglée et
n'est pas réglé à cause des conséquences
que le règlement de cette question aura
sur le niveau de leurs droits et leurs
obligations
donc en dont les américains deal les
chinois ont émergé et donc maintenant
réciprocité et les chinois disent on est
en train d'émerger enfin quand même
notre pnb par tête c'est en haut en plus
d'un dixième du vôtre donc nous
expliquer pas qu'on est comme vous et
qu'on est en état de prendre les mêmes
d'obligations que vous ça c'est la
première raison laurence qui ont
retrouve de manière quasi identique dans
les négociations commerciales et dans
les annonces ont une grossesse en
s'offrant climatique
c'est exactement le même problème qui
est en cause la deuxième raison qui fait
que le système pied n'est évidemment est
due à la crise
nous savons depuis 2008 que les
gouvernements ont d'autres priorités que
l'action internationale nous savons
aussi dans notre sagesse collective que
s'ils coopéraient davantage au niveau
international on sortirait plus vite de
la crise je crois que c'est absolument
évident que ça se démontre assez
facilement
malheureusement
heureusement ce qui prime c'est le local
ce qui prime c'est les ennuis que les
gouvernements chez eux c'est la crainte
qui n'ont de perdre les prochaines
élections parce que le niveau de chômage
ou le destruction des tissus économiques
et sociaux est tel que ceci provoque des
réactions politiques extrêmement forte
sans précédent et c'est normal
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de crise dans l'histoire de l'humanité
qui est était aussi globale profonde et
brutale que celle qu'on a vécue depuis
2008 et dans ces circonstances le peu
d'énergie politiques qui restent à des
gouvernements en général délégitimer par
l'agrile il le consacre un boucher des
trous à la maison et pas à s'occuper des
questions internationales et d'ailleurs
je vois ça physiquement absolument
évidemment dans la succession des g20
depuis le premier jusqu'à jusqu'au
dernier en novembre dernier
on voit bien quand on est autour de
cette table quel est le niveau de
coopération que le langage corporel de
ceux qui participent exprime et c'est
vrai que là on est dans une période
extrêmement difficile donc c'est une
réalité qui à mon avis va durer aussi
longtemps que la crise durera il ya une
synergie entre ces deux ces deux
éléments
c'est à dire la recompositions
géopolitiques et les effets de la créer
parce que l'effet de la crise
c'est d'augmenter le différentiel de
croissance entre les pays développés et
les pays en voie développement en gros
avant la crise
c'était de l'ordre de 1 à 2 après la
crise
pendant la crise d'ores et déjà
aujourd'hui ce différentiel et dans de
1,3 avoir un à quatre ce qui accentue
dans le monde occidental et notamment
dans une opinion de pays où il ya des
niveaux de chômage
historiquement très élevés ce qui
accentue l'impression que c'est à cause
de la croissance des pays émergents
qu'on a le niveau de chômage qu'on a
si vous prenez nous nous focalisons pas
sur l'europe sur la france pour ne pas
risquer de tomber dans des turbulences
électorale si vous prenez l'état de
l'opinion américaine
c'est absolument évident donc ça c'est
une situation avec laquelle nous allons
devoir hélas je suis un des premiers à
le regretter
nous allons devoir vivre aussi longtemps
que les questions de coopération
internationale ne joueront pas dans le
jeu politique national
une force équivalent à la prévalence des
questions locales
et c'est là que j'en suis d'ailleurs
arrivé après avoir pensé d'autres choses
dans d'autres villes dans d'autres
expériences professionnelles que la
gouvernance globale
c'est pas de globaliser des problèmes
locaux c'est de localiser les problèmes
globaux
je pense fondamentalement que c'est la
vraie solution au déficit de gouvernance
auxquels nous faisons face
et encore une fois c'est vrai en matière
commerciale parce qu'on n'a pas fait de
progrès on a un système qui existe qui
est beaucoup plus sophistiqué beaucoup
plus fourni qui est beaucoup plus
élaboré que beaucoup d'autres mais c'est
vrai que récemment on n'a pas fait de
progrès c'est vrai en matière
environnementale c'est vrai en matière
de coordination économique
le macro économiques 1 prenez le
problème du g20 sur la surveillance
multilatérale que le fmi doit faire des
principales grandes heures économiques y
compris les taux de change ont accompli
dire c'est que ça n'avance pas donc pour
l'instant c'est malheureusement la
situation sur ce ce que tu disais sur le
développement durable juste il y a à
baisieux et gelé
écrit au secrétaire général des nations
unies a pas très longtemps une certaine
un certain rétrécissement de la notion
de développement durable rio c'était la
durabilité au sens environnemental au
sens économique au sens social rio +20
il ya un certain rétrécissement de la
composante économique et social de cette
notion de durabilité qui à mon avis est
fait occupante parce que mon expérience
et notamment la fréquentation assidue
des pays en développement que je que
j'ai par par fonction me montre que ces
trois éléments sont indissociables on
peut pas jouer la durabilité
environnementale contre la durabilité
économique on peut pas jouer la dure
amical contre la durabilité sociale et
les connexions entre la durabilité
sociale et la durabilité
environnementale sont évidentes
donc là il ya effectivement de mon point
de vue encore un point d'interrogation
sur l' équilibre correct pour ce qui est
de rio cette année d'un ping social
environnemental
je voudrais qu'on y revienne si tu veux
bien quand tu m'auras donner une
définition suffisamment précise de ce
que veut dire dumping social et
environnemental
je ne sais pas très bien ce que c'est ou
plus exactement il n'y a que si tu
précises ce culture entend par là que je
suis en état de répondre
topping sociale et ou environnemental
sur sur l'apport au mca riom j'en
esquissé les principales contributions
possibles l'assurance
antiprotectionnistes qu'offre le web et
qui devrait être de nature à
décontracter un peu les pays en
développement
la négociation dans le cycle de doha sur
les biens et services environnementaux
c'est à dire sur la réduction des stades
des obstacles aux échanges assez bien et
les progrès en matière de discipline sur
les subventions à la pêche
or il est vrai que ces éléments que je
cite sont pour l'instant dans l'ensemble
dû prendre deux doigts ça fait partie
des 20 sujets dont on s'était dit au
départ quand ce cas d'accord sur rien
tant qu'on n'était pas d'accord sur tout
vous savez sans doute qu'en ce moment on
est en train d'essayer de sortir un
certain nombre de ses sujets un par un
pour les faire avancer
pourquoi pas la négociation sur les
biens et services environnementaux
biens et services environnementaux ou
ceux sur les subventions à la pêche même
si on retrouve là des différences
géopolitique assez profonde sur le
principe de réciprocité mais ce visage
et j'ai répondu il n'y a pas d'un côté
en matière de gouvernance
gardons le principe selon lequel sauf
preuve du contraire qui serait décidé
par les membres de toutes ces
organisations et je n'en vois pas la
preuve
chacun a sa spécialité donc la
gouvernance de l'environnement
c'est avec les organisations
environnementales les accords
multilatéraux sur l'environnement
ce sont des accords qui ont leurs
propres spécificités
que ce soit la biodiversité que ce soit
d'ailleurs beaucoup de ces accords
comportent des dispositions commerciales
la convention la commune sur
l'environnement sur le sur l'épreuve le
commerce des produits toxiques
il sait pas un accord omc c'est un
accord environnemental
l'accord sur
commerce des espèces protégées c'est pas
un accord oem c'est bien qu'ils aient
comme airs de man c'est un accord
environnemental
donc il ya différents pôles de
régulation dont certains ont des
conséquences commerciales sans que ceux
ci aient pose moins de problèmes à l'om
cm mais l'om c'est ne peut pas se
transformer en instance de régulation
sectorielle
il ya des règles qui gouvernent le
commerce de la viande
ceux qui sont en charge de la définition
de ce commerce de la viande du pain du
sanitaire c'est le fils internationale
des épizooties rue prenez à paris à l'om
c'est parce que c'est leur spécialité
parce que c'est le mandat que les
membres de l'office international des
écrivains dits se sont donnés de même
que on a inventé depuis 2008 une
organisation mondiale de la finance qui
ne porte pas ce moment là qui est à bâle
qui est le forum de stabilité financière
qui est en charge de déterminer la
régulation multilatérale en matière de
règles prudentielles pour la
finance-assurance les règles de bâle et
c'est donc l'om sait n'a aucune vocation
à se substituer à ces négociations et à
ces organisations sectorielles
elle ne veut pas le faire pas parce que
l'om c'est un essai de personnalités qui
viendraient de la q2 du pi terre mais
parce que le mandat du mcc les membres
de l'om c'est qu'ils en ont donné ces
les membres de worms et qui conduisent
au mc moi je suis là factotum à un
certain point de vue mais ce sont eux
qui conduisent et ils ont décidé que ce
système de régulation internationale
était spécialisé
et ça restera de cette manière est ce
que pour autant il n'y a pas une
coexistence entre des règles de
protection de l'environnement et des
règles d'ouverture des échanges qui est
apprécié à l'om c'est bien sûr il ya
depuis 1995 un comité de l'om c'est
comme vous avez des commissions au sénat
nous on a des comités au lieu d'avoir
des commissions qui s'appelle le comité
commerce et l'environnement comme en
voit sur le comédien assure mme koné a
décerné sa sur la propriété
intellectuelle et ce comité commerce et
environnement examine des sujets des
notifications quant aux titres par
exemple des obstacles techniques au
commerce
un cancan là quand l'un quand l'union
européenne a décidé d'une législation
sur la traçabilité des produits
chimiques la fameuse directive reach la
question de savoir si cette directive
est conforme à l'accord sur les
barrières techniques au commerce a été
examinée à plusieurs employés par ce
comité
donc ces questions là elles sont
soulevés elles sont examinées et en cas
de désaccord elles vont au contentieux
et le contentieux va interpréter
l'accord sur les barrières techniques au
commerce ou en l'occurrence accord sur
les normes sanitaires et phytosanitaires
puisque c'est là que se trouvent les
principes d'articulation entre
l'ouverture des échanges et la
préservation de l'environnement
donc encore une fois ça n'est pas une
question de savoir s'il ou mc doit se
substituer à ou doit s'occuper d'eux en
l'absence d'une organisation d'un
dispositif d'un système de discipline ça
n'est pas notre rôle est donc pour
répondre à la question de monsieur le
dantec
où sont les règles les règles elles sont
dans les organisations dans les systèmes
dans les accords qui sont spécialisés à
cet effet nous n'avons pas
à l'om c'est à définir ça n'est pas
notre rôle
quel est le bon niveau d'émission de
carbone
pour l'europe les états unis le japon ou
la chine
alors si un jour vient un contentieux
parce qu'une mesure a été prise au nom
de la préservation de l'environnement
en l'absence d'un système de la
régulation internationale eimp que si en
un a priori ya pas de problème s'il y en
a pas un problème
c'est pour ça que j'aimerais mieux
qu'ils en aient d'ailleurs que je vais
essayer de le dire en conclusion si on
n'a pas alors le tribunal de aïn sebaâ
examinées au cas par cas
la proportionnalité la balance on
appelle le test de nécessiter entre les
uns et les autres je vais vous donner un
exemple pour vous faire comprendre d'un
contentieux qu'élus et quelques années
entre les européennes et le brésil le
brésil avait interdit l'importation de
pneus rechapés motif étant que les plus
riches à pessah se retrouve dans la
campagne et que c'est des nids à
moustiques et que les nids à moustiques
c'est mauvais pour l'environnement et
pour la santé l'union européenne je
n'étais plus commissaire à l'époque je
tiens à le préciser en tant que des
besoins intenté un procès au brésil en
disant votre mesure ne rechapés que vous
prenez pour des raisons apparemment
environnementale en réalité est une
mesure de protection de vos producteurs
de pneus neufs et eu un procès à l'om
c'est que le brésil a gagné sur le fond
et que l'union européenne a gagné sur
les fêtes
qu'est ce que le juge a dit le juge a
dit considérant que le brésil a le droit
de protéger son environnement en
interdisant des pneus rechapés donnant
raison au brésil sur le principe mais
considérant que
cette mesure ne s'appliquait pas au sein
du mercosur ce qui fait que le brésil
pouvait importer des produits des plus
rechapés d'argentine uruguay ou du
paraguay et donc il y avait des
discriminations y avait deux
environnements suis pour les
exportateurs européens et celui pour les
exportateurs argentin est donc le
tribunal a dit votre truc ça ne va pas
si vous étiez vraiment sur un fondement
environnemental alors vous auriez
interdit toutes les importations de
pneus rechapés venant de partout donc
voilà le type je vous donne cet exemple
non pas pour rentrer trop dans le détail
mais faut pour vous donner disons les
conditions dans lesquelles ces choses
s'apprécie au plan en contentieux sur
les grands émergents
je vous renvoie un article à paraître
dans esprit que j'ai commis sur cette
question
c'est évidemment que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la question fondamentale c'est
quelle est leur place
sont ils prêts à prendre des
responsabilités sont ils prêts à prendre
des responsabilités dans le système tel
qu'il a été conçu depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale et sans influer sur les
règles de ce système non je résume leur
position nous voulons bien prendre des
ordres des obligations internationales
nous sommes prêts à souscrire des
disciplines nous chinois reconnaissons
parfaitement que sur le plan de
l'environnement ou du commerce
nous sommes prêts à prendre des
obligations ou à ce score discipline
supérieure à celle du laos du sénégal ou
du kenya une tare mais d'autre part nous
voulons que le jeu sur les règles les
positions dans le système les quotas au
fmi
les actions la banque mondiale soient
rééquilibrées
nous ne nous ne voulons pas sous traiter
ce que maintenant nous nous sommes
émergents nous contenter de participer à
un système dont vous avez fixé les
règles
est-ce qu'ils ont les demandes assez
précise sur l'endroit où il souhaiterait
que ces règles il faut modifier
je n'irai pas toujours jusque là mais
disons ils ont ils ont ils ont une
attitude qui est très très marquée par
la préservation de leur souveraineté et
de ce point de vue là d'ailleurs il y à
l'émergence des émergents a provoqué un
retour du souverainisme dans la
politique multilatérale en ceci
d'ailleurs en conformité avec tout un
tas de théories sur le développement du
tiers-monde et donc ça c'est vraiment la
question et je crois que vous avez vous
voyez juste en tout cas l'intuition que
vous avez et celle que j'ai même si
jusqu'à présent je ne vais pas
développer en modèle serait opérationnel
c'est effectivement une affaire de temps
mais quand vous dites pays en
développement nous faisons tous
intellectuellement
une hypothèse qui est qu'un jour ils
seront développés et les amodiations du
système au système de la réciprocité que
vous puissiez tout à l'heure sont fondés
sur les hypothèses implicites qu'un jour
nous le montre a développé la question
c'est de savoir si c'est si ses
dimensions temporelles qui est en
quelque sorte externalisés dans nos
hypothèses peut-être internaliser dans
des accords là on touche une zone très
très difficile donc vous voyez bien dans
les négociations sur quoi mon climatique
comme d'ailleurs on ne voit l'om c'est
que pour l'instant elle n'a pas été
vraiment explorer parce qu'il est très
très très sensible
et en plus elle amène et c'est sans
doute les raisons pour lesquelles c'est
très difficile elle amène en réalité à
une différenciation
elle amène à la reconnaissance qu'il ya
probablement pas de vitesse mais trois
mais sortir de la logique des deux
vitesses
par exemple dans la gangue idéologique
qu'est celle de l'assemblée générale des
nations-unies g77 veut dire le g20 d'un
certain point de vue et je me fera pas
ça dans le compte rendu ou s'il vous
plaît le g20 casse le g77 et casser le
g77 et un gros problème pour les
diplomates des pays en développement à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
parce que très souvent il est un sujet
sur lequel il suffit de mettre la
bannière du g77 et à ce moment là haut
up les votes partent d'un côté ou de
l'autre
à peu près à peu près est ce que je vous
ai surpris notamment en disant que
l'ouverture des échanges
servez le développement durable je pense
que je peux le démontrer rapidement
moyennement rapidement ou longuement
c'est c'est pour une raison très simple
que monsieur riccardo avec en son époque
correctement expliqué qui est que si je
fais quelque chose mieux vous et si vous
faites quelque chose mieux - nous avons
tous les deux intérêt à des changes et
dans le mieux dans votre mieux ou dans
mon mieux il ya effectivement
l'utilisation est ce que ces
utilisations est ce que ces
exploitations c'est une affaire de
préférences politiques des ressources
que vous mettez en oeuvre
vous allez faire quelque chose de mieux
que - parce que pour faire la même chose
vous allez consommer moins de ressources
qu'elles soient humaines qu'elles soient
naturelles qu'elles soient en capital
parce que c'est votre savoir faire qui
vous permet de le faire je n'ai pas
votre savoir faire mais j'en ai un nom
un autre endroit que vous n'avez pas et
donc le résultat tout ça c'est de
l'échangé international et un échange
international qui nous le savons pousse
à la division internationale du travail
il suffit de voir d'ailleurs ce que
c'est que le commerce international
aujourd'hui qui contrairement à une idée
répandue ne consiste pas à produire
quelque chose dans un pays a exporté
dans un autre pays où les consommer
l'essentiel du commerce international
aujourd'hui ce sont des composants ce
sont des chaînes de production globale
dans lesquelles vous importez des
composants auxquelles vous ajouter de la
valeur en fonction de vos avantages peut
paraître libre de votre savoir faire et
vous le réexporter 70% des importations
de la france aujourd'hui sont des
matières premières ou des composants 70%
le contenu en importations des
exportations moyenne sur cette planète
est passé au cours des vingt dernières
années de 20% à 40% et à mon avis dans
20 ans on sera au delà de 60 %
pourquoi parce que il ya un formidable
effet qui est dû aux progrès
technologiques de réduction des coûts de
la distance ce qui limitait les progrès
de la division internationale du travail
et de la différenciation des avantages
comparatifs des uns et des autres
c'était les coûts de frottement liés à
la distance parce que ça coûtait cher
d'envoyer un conteneur de marseille à
shanghai plus exactement au bugue
si vous faites c'est en conteneurs vous
diviser le coût du transport à la tonne
d'un facteur de 50 par rapport par
rapport au rac
je passe sur internet
donc ça c'est le commerce international
d'aujourd'hui en ce qu'il autorise une
multiplication des tâches c'est plus du
commerce de produits c'est du commerce
de tâches
voilà pour à l'audition de pascal lamy
directeur général de l'om c'est pour
revoir cette audition notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
très bonne fin de soirée à tous sur
public sénat